[Music]
we are going to take the show to Dallas
I heard and I know that you've you know
born and raised born and raised in
Dallas and so that got me thinking
Angie Herman's coming on the show we're
taking our show for a week in Dallas you
know love it what do we need to know you
have to go to me cocina it's a
restaurant in Highland Park Village okay
you have to go there immediately you get
off the plane you go directly can I go
nap should we just leave now
yeah cuz yes with the waters right there
we could take a long way around and you
have to have they have an amazing drink
they're called the Mambo taxi the Mambo
tank yes what's in the Mambo and this is
like kind of special to Dallas yes okay
you it's frozen margarita and frozen
sangria together but the there's a catch
you can only have three of them what do
you mean I mean you can only have three
of them that just sounds like a
challenge
yeah it is you brought a mambo taxi yes
can everybody I brought three okay
that's true oh good and so I think that
you should vote AXI it is the Mambo taxi
all right thank you all right and then
this is yours and this is yours wow this
is the Mambo test oh well here
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
well that is really good
only three and it packs a punch yeah
that has yeah and what's what are the
shots all about hmm
well those are just shots if you want to
do just about alcoholism yeah what are
you supposed to do anything with the is
this is the shot supposed to be or is it
oh yeah where you squeeze it on
somebody's body and then you're lately
you're squeezing over the lime on
somebody's body and then you lick it on
your put salt
[Applause]
you see you put the lime in there or the
man show me what to do okay well and
then okay wait really
I mean would you go to Harvard or
something my god look my hands all about
him the folks over here
Oh guys in a bowtie and then what okay
count I'm gonna watch you go okay
first you lick us all got it under then
take your shot and then do your line
right
[Music]
we
[Applause]
why Jeff just said to me I wish I had my
sketchpad
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you for coming have good job